I'm going to unite the six strings and
destroy all music so I'm gonna need your
string four years ago the DreamWorks
Animation featured trolls dropped a
glitter bomb upon the world delighting
fans of all ages with its colorful
fantasy adventure and pop music
soundtrack the movie was an instant
box-office success an Oscar nominee and
a Grammy winner and it spawned a holiday
special for NBC and a television series
for Netflix now it's time for a sequel
here's everything you need to know
before you watch trolls world tour is
the feature follow-up that families have
been waiting for as not just a return to
the world of poppy branch guy diamond
and the rest of the trolls but also an
introduction to an expanded universe of
miniature musical creatures featuring
all new characters and songs released in
2016 and inspired by the classic troll
doll figures the original movie
introduced us to the land of princess
poppy and her fellow fun-loving and
brightly colored little creatures they
lived relatively carefree partying and
singing pop songs together until they
were rediscovered by their enemy the
Bergin's which were larger ogre like
monsters who wanted to eat the trolls
after a bunch of their friends were
kidnapped by a villainous Bergen chef
the always hopeful poppy and her
pessimistic pal branch journeyed to
Bergen town on a rescue mission along
the way they befriend a Bergen girl
helped her woo the spoiled New King got
her to help save the other trolls and
ultimately brought peace between the
trolls and the Bergin's for fans of
trolls and it's lovable characters the
two small screen spin-offs are worth
watching but not necessary ahead of the
new movie but there may be some
references to trolls holiday and the new
series trolls the beat goes on
Charles holiday is a half-hour animated
short in which puppy and friends find
the Bergin's a new holiday now that
they've done away with trustus which was
the time when the creatures feasted on
trolls the beat goes on which ran for
eight seasons through last year simply
offers an episodic look at the life and
trolls village following the event
of the first movie tros world tour takes
place after the events of the first
trolls movie but there have been
contradictory reports on whether the
film is set before or after the holiday
special and television series from the
looks of it the chronology doesn't
really matter either way since the new
movie tells an isolated story and unlike
the spin-offs doesn't really feature the
bergen's the plot of the movie involves
a threat from another land of trolls
poppy who is now queen and the rest of
our village discovered there are five
other kinds of trolls each group
representing a different genre of music
and the leaders of the heart Rock trolls
want to do away with classical country
funk techno and pop the last of which
being Poppy's domain and reigns supreme
poppy is once again voiced by Anna
Kendrick who is reunited with Justin
Timberlake as branch now Poppy's
boyfriend other returning trolls include
guy diamond Biggie Cooper DJ Sookie and
the twins chenille and satin voiced
respectively by Kunal Nayyar James
Corden Ron Funches Gwen Stefani and the
electro pop duo
Icona pop some additions for the sequel
include Rachel bloom and Ozzy Osbourne
who voiced the villains queen Barb and
her father king thrash of the hard rock
trolls mary j blige and George Clinton
play the leaders of the funk trolls
Anthony Ramos plays the head of the
techno trolls Kelly Clarkson plays the
mayor of the country trolls and Sam
Rockwell plays another country troll
also joining the cast of musical
characters most of whom will also be
heard on the soundtrack are Jamie Dornan
Charlyne Yi Flula Borg Karin Soni
Saturday Night Live cast member Kenan
Thompson reggaeton singer Jay Bolin
singer and rapper Anderson PAC singer
ester dean violinist Gustavo Dudamel and
the members of the k-pop group red
velvet who are you guys we are the kpop
game speaking of the soundtrack that
trolls world tour album features some
brand new tracks led by
singer-songwriter producer Justin
Timberlake similar to the first movies
award-winning hit can't stop the feeling
including the other side featuring
scissor and don't slack with Anderson
pack there's also a country song
co-written by
Timberlake and Chris Stapleton plus
other original tunes with the rest of
the cast as four covers performed by the
stars of trolls world tour including
Kendrick Gordon and Clinton there's a
melody of girls just want to have fun
good times and groove is in the heart as
well as a new version of Clinton's
atomic dog bloom covers the rock hits
Barracuda rock you like a hurricane and
Osborne's own crazy train while Ramos
sings deaf punks one more time and
Rockwell sings Patsy Cline's I fall to
pieces Rockwell who makes only his
second vocal appearance in an animated
feature is known for his dancing and not
so much for his musical talent but he
does love to sing and he's been heard
minimally doing so in such movies as
glory days and three billboards outside
Evan Missouri
Walter Dorn who made his feature
directorial debut as the co-director of
the first trolls and continues as the
voice of various characters including
mr. tinkles is now the lead director of
trolls world tour he's joined by
co-director David P Smith a longtime
employee of DreamWorks Animation who in
turn makes his feature directorial debut
with this new sequel so now you know and
now you can go watch trolls world tour
exclusively on digital platforms
including Fandango now on April 10th
[Music]